Isis's leader meets his end at the hands
of the amazing American military the
Washington Post issues the world's worst
headline and Democrats am a little
nervous about the DOJ investigation into
the Trump Russia investigation I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
Express VPN protect your online privacy
today and expressvpn comm /ban well it
is wonderful wonderful news today
wonderful news
al-baghdadi who is the leader of Isis
Abu Bakr al Baghdadi is dead at the age
of 48 and in died of natural causes
which is great I don't want him to die
of natural causes I wanted to suffer I
wanted things to be very terrible for
him unfortunately as we will see al
Baghdadi's death brought with it the
death of more innocents because this is
what terrorists do President Trump
announced his death yesterday on Sunday
morning and let's just say it was an
amazing moment for the Trump presidency
we'll get to that in just one second
first you know right now things seem
pretty chaotic things seen things seem
pretty much in flux well when things are
chaotic when things are in flux when it
feels like governments may be
manipulating their currency for economic
purposes people tend to take their money
and put it into safe assets and the
safest asset of all is gold I mean this
has been the safest asset for hundreds
of years and nothing has changed there's
a reason that gold is currently sitting
at its five-year high and there's also a
reason why smart investors have always
diversify dat least a little bit into
precious metals I've been telling you
for years if you are not protecting your
investment and your family with gold the
way that I am you are missing the boat
inflation the national debt global
instability the fact is all of these
factors can really hit your dollar
savings and they can also hit your
stocks the same thing is not true of
precious metals which have never been
worth zero Birch gold will go to work
and make things very simple for you if
you had taken the first step of
requesting a free information kit on
gold you shouldn't wait it is indeed
free Birch gold we'll have a
conversation with you you can determine
if precious metals investing makes sense
to include in your portfolio again make
sense for my portfolio I think that
you'll agree that diversify me at least
a little bit into precious metals as I
say maybe more than a little bit is a
good idea I trust the folks at Birch
gold I've known them for quite a while
as you know from listening to the show
again you should hold some precious
metals in Birch gold they're the people
I trust texts Benz you 47 47 47 today to
see how simple and straightforward the
move can be for you again texts been to
47 47 47 that's been to 47 47 47 okay so
the killing of Abu Bakr al Baghdadi is
indeed a wonderful moment for the United
States obviously everybody is comparing
this to the killing of Osama bin Laden
the President of the United States
President Trump it is similar in some
ways it is different in some ways
obviously bin Laden had taken on a
certain shade in the American
imagination thanks to 9/11 that bag bag
daddy never did
however killing the leader of global
terror movement is obviously a massive
massive achievement particularly by the
American military as well as listen
President Trump gave the order so he
gets the credit in the same way that
Barack Obama gave the order about bin
Laden and he gets the credit now as we
will see shortly the media are not
willing to give President Trump the
credit in the same way they gave Barack
Obama the credit
we got years of president from gutsy
call gutsy call the gutsiest gutsy call
that ever happened and at the time I was
like oh no he just authorized a mission
to kill the most wanted terrorists in
the history of earth so not super gutsy
especially considering the circumstances
surrounding it but you know listen he
got he got credit he's the President of
the United States and then obviously he
ran on that hey Joe Biden who's now
running again in 2016 Joe Biden in 2012
repeatedly went to rallies and said
Detroit is dead bin Laden is dead and
Detroit is alive that was one of their
slogans right bin Laden is dead Detroit
is alive as you'll see the media very
angry at President Trump today why are
they very angry at President who's
president Trump's that means they're
going to attempt to draw back on the
victory pretend that it wasn't that big
a deal suggests that in fact it'll be
counterproductive in a variety of ways
they're suggesting also that President
Trump his policies are undercut by the
killing of Baghdady they're trying to
suggest of course that President Trump
really doesn't get credit for any of
this stuff and so we remember how
honorable Barack Obama was in his
announcement don't you remember all of
that
hey don't worry we'll go through all of
it because the fact is Trump's
announcement yesterday was pretty
fantastic and there are a lot of people
who are on top of President Trump
specifically because Trump was very
graphic about how all bad daddy was
killed good good I'm glad
got a piece of crap not only was you
piece of crap people who would join the
Islamic state should know that this is
how they will die if they join the
Islamic state at the hands of the
American military cowering in fear and
shame and pathetic self pitying mewling
is how they will go they'll go with an
American gun coming for them and not
only that they should know that their
leadership are a bunch of cowards they
should know that because the fact is
that unfortunately in the terror world
it is the perception of the strong horse
that drives people to join terror groups
if P
thing the leadership of terror groups
are a bunch of pathetic cowards who
murder innocent children their own
innocent children well maybe that would
change the math a little bit we'll get
to all that in just a second first here
the actual details according to the UK
Daily Mail Isis leader Abu Bakr al
Baghdadi was killed when he detonated a
suicide vest as US Army Special Ops
forces closed in on his hideout in
northwestern Syria between 50 and 70
members of the US Army Delta Force and
Rangers flew in on six helicopters and
surrounded al Baghdadi's during the
overnight raid on Syria's it Lib
province an official source told Fox
News details about the raid are still
emerging as officials conduct biometric
tests on evidence collected from the
site an unverified video reportedly
showed the moment al Baghdadi was killed
along with his three children because
evil pieces of garbage like Baghdadi
aren't gonna go into hell alone I mean
presumably his kids will not go to hell
because they were innocent in all of
this but he brought them with him into
with this wherever he was this cave and
then blew himself up along with his
three young children because a piece of
human feces President Trump held the
morning press conference on Sunday and
confirmed that Baghdady quote-unquote
died like a dog defense secretary mark
espera said there were two minor
injuries to u.s. soldiers after Trump
indicated that US canine was injured as
well so here is what President Trump had
to say about the operation he was
watching this from the Situation Room
the White House did release a photo from
the situation when very much like the
photo released of Barack Obama watching
the raid on the bin Laden compound in
Pakistan when bin Laden was killed in
2012 ever lose 2011 in any case here was
here was a president Trump's statement
last night last night the United States
brought the world's number-one terrorist
leader to justice Abu Bakar al Baghdadi
is dead he was the founder and leader of
Isis the most ruthless and violent
terror organization anywhere in the
world the United States has been
searching for Baghdadi
for many years capturing or killing
Baghdadi has been the top national
security priority of my administration
US Special Operations Forces executed a
dangerous and daring nighttime raid
in northwestern Syria and accomplished
their mission and grand style okay well
there's the president announcing what
exactly happened the president also of
course giving the credit to the US
military which is where the credit
belongs he then goes on to describe
exactly what happened and a lot of
people media are very upset that he
described all of the details of the
operation frankly I think it's a good
thing I think that again terrorists
should know that if you attack American
citizens if you fight American allies if
you forcibly convert people or behead
them that the US military is coming for
you and it ain't gonna be pretty the
greatest fighting force in the history
of the world will come for you and you
will meet your end the same way that bin
Laden did and Baghdad he did here as
President Trump getting pretty detailed
and pretty graphic about what happened
good for him
the u.s. personnel were incredible I got
to watch much of it no personnel were
lost in the operation well a large
number of Baghdadi's fighters and
companions were killed with him he died
after running into a dead-end tunnel
whimpering and crying and screaming all
the way the compound had been cleared by
this time with people either
surrendering or being shot and killed
good good so there are a lot of people
very upset with Trump saying oh he was
whimpering and crying how could Trump
say this sort of thing
why didn't he treat him with a modicum
of honor remember this in the aftermath
of the bin Laden killing there's a lot
of talk about what happened to bin
Laden's body and President Obama
announced that it had been dropped at
sea and that it had been put out at sea
because out of respect because he didn't
want to make a martyr out of him okay
this is the opposite of making a martyr
out of somebody when you say that the
person was a coward when you say that
the person was just a ridiculous wretch
of a human being who is crying and
screaming and mewling as he went out
okay people were saying well this is
gonna drive Isis to new heights first of
all you don't need to piss off Isis okay
the fact is Isis they're kind of famous
for not liking Americans and Westerners
I don't think that you need to actually
push Isis in order to attack the West
there may be a slight upswing in terror
in the aftermath of a telling like this
that is sort of natural because whenever
you kill a major terror leader then the
group wants to show that it is not in
fact to funked but it's not Trump's word
that are going to do that is the
absolute it's the killing of Baghdady
that would presumably result in this
kind of brief upswing and terror but it
does great damage to take out their
leader and yes it does great damage also
to point out that the person was a
pathetic coward president from fen
wedding into even greater detail about
all of this talking about the children
and what bog daddy did it is very end
eleven young children were moved out of
the house and are uninjured the only
ones remaining were back daddy in the
tunnel and he had dragged three of his
young children with him
they were led to certain death he
reached the end of the tunnel as our
dogs chased him down he ignited his vest
killing himself and the three children
his body was mutilated by the blast the
tunnel had caved in on it in addition
but test results gave certain immediate
and totally positive identification it
was him okay and president Trump then
continued this was the theme okay the
main theme of his address was what a
pathetic coward Baghdad he was he came
back to this team later he talked about
Baghdad II as a sick and depraved man
which of course he certainly certainly
was he was a sick and depraved man and
now he's gone Baghdad II was vicious and
violent and he died in a vicious and
violent way as a coward running and
crying good good good I mean really good
let the world know that radical Islamic
terrorists who purport to be the bravest
among us they purport to be just the the
wisest and the wise is the most holy the
bravest just filled with courage that
one in the American soldiers come for
them when the forces of the West come
for them when the forces of the United
States when America's military comes for
them that they are crying all the way
good good I mean Frank I think it's a
great thing I think it's a I think what
Trump said here is fantastic and not
only do I have no qualms about it I am
when President Trump says all of this
now President Trump then makes the only
reference really that he makes to his
leadership in in all of this in in this
clip he talks about how backed out he
was on the run for many years long
before he took office here's what it
sounds like
Baghdady has been on the run for many
years long before I took office
but in my direction as
commander-in-chief of the United States
we obliterated his caliphate 100 percent
in March of this year today's events are
another reminder that we will continue
to pursue the remaining Isis terrorists
to their brutal end that also goes for
other terrorist organizations they are
likewise in our sights
President Trump then went on do you
think Russia Turkey Syria and Iraq all
the involved nations and he said he
wanted to thank the Syrian Kurds for the
support they were able to give us and he
said thank you to intelligence
professionals and he concluded by saying
that last night was a great night for
the United States and for the world here
is what President Trump had to say last
night was a great night for the United
States and for the world a brutal killer
one who has caused so much hardship and
death has violently been eliminated he
will never again harm another innocent
man woman or child he died like a dog he
died like a coward the world is now a
much safer place god bless america
good good good good good and everybody
you'll see people on the Left how could
he say he died like a dog he keeps
saying legged dog hey there's one of
trumps favorite phrases like it up if
you're gonna say somebody died like a
dog okay which is a very very old phrase
in the United States well then this
would seem to be an appropriate instance
of using now like there are many times
when he has said like a dog where I'm
like not sure it's like a dog in this
particular case I'm with it man
I'm all-in I mean it good is it person
who not only deserved to die the person
deserved to die in the worst possible
way his person was
piece of debris this person was a speck
on the shoe of humanity and president
Trump to riding him after his death is
more than well deserved it is more than
well deserved okay in just a second
we're gonna get to the press's reaction
to this suffice to say they're less
enthused then I am overall about the
death of Baghdady
they're downplaying it they're saying
that Trump really wasn't responsible for
it and will contrast that with what they
had to say about Osama bin Laden because
it is pretty telling about the
journalism of the mainstream media get
to that in just one second first you
know what Baghdady could have used aside
from a place to hide and not being a
horrible terrorist you could have used
some life insurance because the fact is
then when you die everybody needs life
insurance if you want to properly
provide for your family you need life
insurance you do most people need ten
times the life insurance coverage they
get through their job even if your job
is providing that life insurance which
means that your employer life insurance
is probably leaving you underinsured and
this is where policy genius comes in
policy genius is the easy way to shop
for a life insurance plan that is not
tied to your job in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will then handle all
the paperwork as well as the red tape
the life insurance you buy through
policy genius it stays with you even if
you leave your job and policy genius
doesn't just make it easy to buy life
insurance they can also help you find
the right home and auto insurance
disability insurance - they make it
really really simple and they they
really make the process easier and
faster so when you are looking at your
workplace benefits this month make sure
to double check those life insurance
options then go to policy genius coms
get quotes and apply in men as policy
geniuses again the easy way to compare
and buy it life insurance be an adult
make sure your family's taken care of in
case god forbid something should happen
to you policy genius coms get quotes and
apply in minutes okay so the media
quickly responds it to all of us I'm
just gonna read you some of the
headlines from various media outlets now
the worst headline of all was the
Washington Post headline ok the
Washington Post headline is just
unbelievable is a ridiculous joke so
their original headline was Abu Bakar
all about daddy Islamic states
terrorists in chief dies at 48 then they
changed it and their headline was Abu
Bakr al-baghdadi austere religious
scholar at helm of Islamic state dies at
48 because that's what he was known for
being an austere religious scholar like
if you're gonna think of the Washington
Post describing lost your religious
scholars it sort of goes like this
Augustine Aquinas Maimonides Luther
Calvin Abu Bakr al Baghdadi hey what so
they sent off an entire hashtag trending
on Twitter The Washington Post says and
they were indeed hilarious and well
deserved because the fact is what actual
what the actual hell is this headline
like really what in the world is this
headline it's an insane insane headline
and my own riff on this was Charles
Manson famous songwriter and meditation
leaders edit 83 like it's absurd it's
absurd and the fact that the Washington
Post came out they said we apologize
that it was read this way oh do you or
he could have you know not printed a
garbage headline like DAGs is a really
really bad so much journalism happening
right there endless levels of journalism
valda more austere wizard who overcame a
severe facial deformity to achieve dark
lordship debt at 71 washington posted
death notices robbie swab from from
reason said Ramsay Bolton austere
diplomat and animal caretaker passes
away at home surrounded by his dogs post
death notices like come on come on
but it wasn't just that Washington Post
headline okay Bloomberg politics around
this headline you ready Islamic state
leader Abu Bakr al-baghdadi transformed
himself from a little-known teacher of
Quranic recitation into the
self-proclaimed ruler of an entity that
covered swaths of Syria and Iraq it's
really a do-it-yourself story you know I
can up from your bootstraps rags to
riches to rags to chopping people's
heads off and forcibly raping people
story it's one of those stories again a
real story of triumph over over
obstacles
I can't wait for Bloomberg politics is
retrospective headline Nazi leader Adolf
Hitler transformed himself from a
little-known itinerant landscape painter
into the self-proclaimed self-proclaimed
ruler of an entity that covered all of
continental Europe just well well done
well done Bloomberg politics like who
who is like you know what these are good
headlines let's do this these are
obviously outliers when it comes to the
headlines most of the headlines
nearly as bad as this but it does show
the willingness of many in the
mainstream media or some in the
mainstream media to cover some for some
of the world's worst people and you do
see this on a fairly regular basis when
it comes to obituaries for foreign
leaders who die it can be an awful awful
person and the obituary will just be
about how they're really great with
their dogs and they're really into
gardening and then when it's like an
American politician then it's like well
this was a shaded character we really
have to look into like somehow you'll
end up with Mal and Ronald Reagan in the
same basket from obut writers and the
mainstream media sometimes it's that's a
bit of an exaggeration but not much of
one
okay but here are the more mainstream
headlines and you can see what the media
are trying to do here now remember the
coverage when Barack Obama ordered the
mission that ended in the death of Osama
bin Laden was universally glowing
universally glowing right the hashtag
gutsy call trended so it wasn't about
the amazing amazing US military and what
they did in that bin Laden raid all
right this one is here's my view when it
comes to these sorts of killings I
really do believe that it's more about
the unbelievable incredible level of
skill and precision and morality of the
American military than it is about the
commander-in-chief at any time that one
of these things happens because it seems
to me that one of the easiest jobs as
commander-in-chief is to say look
there's the world's leading terrorists
go kill him all right that seems like a
fairly easy job and as far as the idea
that you know if the mission goes wrong
the president pays the price for all of
that that's true but the president pays
the price for everything that goes wrong
how many opportunities that does the
president have to take out Osama bin
Laden or Abu Bakr al-baghdadi that's not
to diminish the presidential level of
risk that is taken when you order one of
these operations but if I'm gonna lay
credit anywhere it's at the feet of the
people who actually go in and double tap
in Laden there's gonna be at the feet of
the people who actually chase Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi into a cave in the middle of
a firefight and watch as he blows
himself sky-high right though those are
the people who really to me deserve
nearly all of the credit their bravery I
don't they bravery that the presidents
don't I mean that like they're the ones
who are in the line of fire and it
always sort of annoyed me when the media
covered the Obama bin Laden thing as
though Obama had repelled down the side
of a helicopter personally gone in there
I'm blown away and blown away bin Laden
like it always annoyed me so I'm not
really fond of that sort of coverage on
either side when it comes to any
president with that said if you're gonna
give that coverage to Obama you
certainly have to give that sort of
to trump but that is not what the media
are doing today the media have all sorts
of qualms amazing who could have
predicted they've all sorts of qualms
about Trump's announcement they have
qualms about the operation they have
qualms about the fact that Trump gave a
shout-out to Russia and to and to the
Turks and to the Syrian Kurds they have
all sorts of issues today issues they
never had with with the killing of Osama
bin Laden that was an unmitigated win
for the United States that ended the
threat of al Qaeda according to many in
the media it was all about President
Obama making the strong gutsy incredible
again hashtag gutsy call trended for
like a week for like a week and it was
it and and to pretend that the Obama
campaign in 2012 did not take advantage
of that is to ignore history it was
literally their campaign slogan their
campaign slogan was Detroit is alive in
bin Laden is dead it was repeated at
nearly every rally for a year says
you'll see the media are very angry at
Trump because these Trump's making
political hay out of this yes he's the
president so did Barack Obama okay they
all you mean you mean he's gonna make
hay out of a out of a massive foreign
policy win the killing of the leading
terrorists on earth no no you don't say
but suddenly the media are very very
upset about all this now let me just I'm
just gonna read you the headlines from
the New York Times and The Washington
Post today so the chief headline is
leader of Islamic state dies in commando
raid u.s. says that's not the terrible
headline I mean normally you'd want it
to be a little bit more active than that
meaning you know us us raids Isis
compound leader kills Elvina but but in
any case it's not a bad headline it's
true okay then we get to then we get to
the other headlines and they are all
editorial they're all editorial okay
Trump knew of plans for the raid when he
pulled troops from Syria the president's
abrupt withdrawal complicated the
Pentagon's plans forcing it to
accelerate the risky operation military
official said so in other words the only
reason this operation happened is
because it from screwed up Syria policy
otherwise we could have waited it would
have been safer now I don't remember
people saying that Barack Obama's troop
drawdown in Afghanistan and battery of a
foreign policy made our mission in
Pakistan more difficult I don't remember
that in the aftermath maybe I'm
forgetting but I don't remember that
sort of headline from the New York Times
there's all the New York Times the day
after the killing of bin Laden then
there's Trump Herald success of mission
seeking al-baghdadi and then it's a
though mr. al-baghdadi never wound in
the American psyche like Osama bin Laden
he proved to be tenacious and dangerous
enemy to the United States and its
allies so immediately they're making
that comparison - to bin Laden of course
then they say the raid was a victory
built on factors Trump - rides high you
see Trump really shouldn't be able to
take any credit for the victory because
Trump doesn't like any of the things
that led to the victory you see they say
the president casts the successful
mission as validation of his
disengagement strategy but it required
intelligence agencies and allies he has
spurned so in other words because Trump
doesn't trust the intelligence agencies
that means that he doesn't get credit
when the intelligence agencies provided
information okay Barack Obama made it
his mission in life to slash the
American military to the bone does that
mean he didn't get credit for the bin
Laden kill he literally forced
sequestration half the cuts to come from
the military there hasn't been a
president in my lifetime who hated the
American military and its growth the way
that Barack Obama did I mean he really
didn't like the American military on a
sort of gut level I mean he was
constantly talking I mean he going way
back in his career early in his campaign
in 2008 he talks about American American
policy in Afghanistan aerating villages
and killing children and but that didn't
take away from the bin Laden killed bin
Laden killing Suleiman Laden kill but
here those are all the New York Times
headlines they get Thomas Friedman's
column al Baghdady is dead the story
doesn't end here
president Trump boasts of defeating the
Islamic state he's only showing how
ignorant he is Jessica Stern in the
world is fighting more than Isis so
there is precisely one positive headline
about the killing of the leader of Isis
and it is the lead headline and all the
rest of them are about the various
shortcomings of Trump administration
policy now as we will see this is not
uncommon the Washington Post does the
exact same thing today so this is really
a great exercise in spotting media bias
if you can't see it it's because you
wish to blind yourself to the media bias
remember it was all hashtag gutsy call
when it was Barack Obama now that it's
Trump Singh we have some open questions
we really need to ask hey we'll get some
more of that in just a second first if
politics is making you lose your hair
maybe you ought to deal with that not by
stopping following politics but by
actually dealing with the hair loss
problem the truth is it ain't the
politics that's making you lose your
hair what's actually making you lose
your hair is the fact that it runs in
your family and as the hair is lost it's
very hard for that hair ever to come
back
why you really ought to focus on keeping
your hair two out of three dudes will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they are 35 the
good news is with today's advancements
in science keeps offers proven
treatments that can combat the symptoms
of hair loss keeps has revolutionized
the way men are treated for hair loss
used to have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get medication
delivered to your home no more waiting
rooms
no more pharmacy checkout lines get
doctor attention and discreet drug
delivery all from the comfort and
privacy of your own home prevention is
the key keeps treatments really do work
they're up to 90 percent effective at
reducing and stopping further hair loss
the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you are going to save so act
fast many men even experience hair
regrowth with keeps treatments find out
why keeps has more five-star reviews
than any of its competitors and nearly
100,000 men trust keeps for their hair
loss prevention medication if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps calm / been their
treatment start at just 10 bucks a month
plus for a limited time you get the
first month free keeps calm / been to
get that first month of treatment for
free that is ke EPS calm / men keeps
calm / then okay so those are the New
York Times headlines the Washington Post
headlines are similarly skeptical
similarly skeptical so the headline in
the Washington Post is Trump says
Islamic state leader Baghdad he blew
himself up as US troops closed in and
then it says some analysts questioned
u.s. ability to prevent Isis resurgence
oh so you mean you're gonna ask like
bigger questions then just Baghdad he's
dead so that doesn't end it okay
literally the Obama campaign was run on
the premise that al Qaeda was basically
defeated and that Isis was the JV team
in 2012 it was run on this premise and
the media didn't have any serious
questions about any of that there were
some of us who were pointing out that
killing bin Laden didn't actually end
the terror threat from al Qaeda but it
was a big win obviously the fact is the
Washington Post had none of those
questions I think it's an okay question
honestly like ok you killed the leader
of Isis does that and that's a fine
question but the Washington Post I do
not remember any of these places running
a headlines the day after the bin Laden
kill gone well you know that's in defeat
Al Qaeda did it that didn't effete al
Qaeda and then it says in creating
spectacle around Baghdad he's dead the
trunk departs from Obama's more measured
tone on bin Laden
that's the headline right Trump departs
from about Obama was so measured about
bin Laden he was so he was so even keel
about bin Laden in creating spectacle
around Baghdad because we know Obama
never created spectacle about bin
Laden's death no spectacle at all I mean
aside from every campaign rally for the
next year and a half no spectacle none
and what I most remember about the
middle Aden speech Obama's announcement
of the bin Laden speech what I really do
remember is how self-effacing
Barack Obama was I remember him just
like putting it all on the American
military oh wait that's not what I
remember at all what I remember him
doing is basically getting up there and
suggesting over and over and over that
he deserved full credit for the bin
Laden kill because it was really really
kind of about him then last August after
years of painstaking work by our
intelligence community I was briefed on
a possible lead to bin Laden it was far
from certain and it took many months to
run this thread to ground
I met repeatedly with my national
security team as we developed more
information about the possibility that
we had located bin Laden hiding within a
compound deep inside Pakistan and
finally last week I determined that we
had enough intelligence to take action
and authorized an operation to get Osama
bin Laden and bring him to justice today
at my direction the United States
launched a targeted operation against
that compound in Abbottabad Pakistan hey
you here Obama in that clip a lot of me
there write a lot of Obama you might say
that he was creating a spectacle around
bin Laden's death you might say that you
might say that Barack listen that's his
prerogative he was the president when
button when bin Laden was killed but
let's be straight about this Barack
Obama was not shy exactly about the
about the killing of Osama bin Laden he
wasn't shy and retiring and by the way
I'm old enough to remember also that him
for all the talk about Barack Obama's
gutsy call there were multiple reports
that Barack Obama canceled the operation
to kill bin Laden on three separate
occasions before finally approving the
may 2nd 2011 Navy SEAL mission it is a
book by Richard minutes her writing that
Obama canceled mission in January 2011
again in February a third time in March
and then there were reports
that he had been asked I'm like a
Thursday to approve the rate and then he
waited for days on end to approve the
raid so you know all the talk about the
gutsy cop but the media didn't have any
of those questions it was a gutsy call
he got the credit and by the way he did
deserve the credit he finally made the
right call he finally made the right
call so he gets the credit but I'm just
gonna point out that the media had none
of these questions about any of this
stuff he's skeptical treatment of the
Baghdady death by the people on the left
all of whom are like yeah we're all
celebrating too but it contrasts very
strongly with the bin Laden's dead it's
all about look it justifies his entire
foreign policy everything did anybody
worried like James clapper who was the
head of of Obama's who's Director of
National Intelligence James clapper he
was worrying over the weekend that
Baghdadi's death could actually
galvanize Isis just I'm wondering when
he was serving in the Obama
administration did he have those same
worries when bin Laden was killed a huge
symbolic meaning for taking out about
buck Donny who has been a target for a
force on time I think and what's gonna
be interesting is to extent to which
this negatively affects Isis or does it
galvanize Isis the remnants of Isis
which still survives as in the ideology
and has franchises and other places
besides Syria
so probably we shouldn't killed him
probably shouldn't killed him you know
might galvanize Isis other places
probably should have let him just like
keep living over there and everything
would have been okay
ambassador Dana Smith who was the Obama
ambassador to Qatar she had a long
thread talking about how terrible it was
that Trump used this sort of language to
describe the death of Baghdad he said
this gruesome vivid and probably
exaggerated description of dogs chasing
down Baghdadi will endanger our
personnel in the region when bin Laden
was killed we were careful to be clear
he had been given a proper Muslim burial
not because we gave a damn about him but
because it was important for our
relationships in the region and safety
also it's how America rules with honor
we don't delight in death like the
terrorists do this description is
horrifying should go without saying but
to be perfectly clear I'm a marking on
the presser not on the actual operation
the killing of Baghdad II was
unquestionably good and necessary okay
but what evidence do we have that
like that the terrorists stop hating us
if we treat their dead with innate
levels of tremendous respect by the way
Trump isn't talking about like Marines
going and pissing on his remains or
something he's talking about what this
guy did it didn't about how Americans
treated his remains it wasn't about us
defacing his remains he's talking about
this guy's end he's talking about this
person was a coward and you shouldn't
follow cowards if you read the writings
of Osama bin Laden so much was writing
is about how the United States is a weak
horse he kept using that phrase a weak
horse the United States was was a paper
tiger the United States didn't have
strong leadership like he was they
weren't brave although the one of the
key tactics that is used by terrorists
is calling their opponents cowards and
portraying themselves as puffed up and
brave and so pointing out to would-be
followers then no actually your leader
is a guy who like blows himself up in a
tunnel with little kids because he's
pathetic
that's not a bad thing that's not a bad
thing now you've also seen members of
the political class immediately
swiveling back to critiquing Trump's
foreign policy generally you can't just
give him a win you have to then swivel
back to his foreign policy generally
which again I'm kind of okay with on a
political level but I'm just gonna point
out the Democrats were not doing this
when it was Barack Obama when Barack
Obama was busily withdrawing American
troops from a rocket and leading to the
rise of Isis at the exact same time that
bin Laden was killed no comment like
that from Nancy Pelosi so Nancy Pelosi
put out a statement saying the death of
all Baghdadi is significant but the
death of this Isis leader does not mean
the death of Isis scores of Isis
fighters remain under uncertain
conditions in Syrian prisons countless
others in the region and around the
world remain intent on spreading their
influence and committing acts of terror
okay all of that may be true right I
kind of I agree with the assessment but
there is something deeply ironic about
the Democrats swiveling from the kill of
a major terrorist leader over to well
president Trump's generalized foreign
policy is bad because they were not
willing I remember this I remember it
vividly when Republicans said the same
thing about bin Laden in 2011 it was oh
well yeah it's just cuz you can't
appreciate the genius of Obama it's
because you don't like Obama you just
can't give him the what I can't just
give him the win okay well why can't you
guys just give him the win
all right fine if that's the way this
game is played then why can't you just
give President Trump the win hey we're
gonna give you some more details of the
actual raid there's pretty good report
in the New York Times by air
Schmidt Helene Cooper and Julian Barnes
talking about how exactly this whole
thing went down we'll get to that in
just one second first the fact is that
it is very difficult to keep track of
your business you know we run a business
here at daily we've got over 100
employees and you really have to know
your business in and out you have to
know when you're in growth mode you have
to know when you are in cutback mode you
have to know every single detail of how
your business works if you don't know
your numbers you don't know your
business but the problem that growing
businesses have and that very often
keeps them from knowing their numbers is
this hodgepodge of business systems that
is out there this is why you need
NetSuite by Oracle it's the business
management software that handles every
aspect of your business in an
easy-to-use cloud platform giving you
the visibility and control you actually
need to grow this is really important to
handling how your business works with
NetSuite you have time money and
unneeded headaches you save them by
managing sales finance and accounting
orders and HR instantly right from your
desktop or phone that is why NetSuite is
the world's number one cloud business
system if you want to know everything
down to the most minut granular detail
about your business you really can't
afford to use anything else right now
NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite comm slash appear oh--that's
NetSuite comm slash up hero and ETSU ite
comm slash up hero and download that
free guide seven key strategies to grow
your profits
NetSuite comm slash Schapiro go check
them out right now okay and just one
second we'll give you some more details
on the actual on the actual raid on the
Baghdady compounds and the death of baa
baa baa gar bakr al baghdadi which again
is a major win for the united states
first you have to go and subscribe over
at daily we're calm when you do for
$9.99 a month you get a subscription
that brings you all sorts of goodies
including full access to our daily wires
amazing app it's here it's fantastic of
your subscriber you can access all of
our contents including articles shows
and more straight from the app all
access subscribers get our new exclusive
discussion features where they can
interact directly with hosts writers and
other special guests the app is
available on Apple and Android so
download today become a subscriber and
come join the fun it really is fantastic
also when you subscribe and do the 99
year 99 bucks a year thing you also get
this the very greatest in all beverage
vessels that left is tears hot or cold
tumblr apparently some of the editors of
the washington post our filling mine
today because my goodness that was a
terrible
go check out all of these affirmation
glories of daily wired icon where the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay according to the New York Times
president Trump knew the CIA and Special
Operations Command OHS were zeroing in
on the location for Abu Bakr al-baghdadi
the Islamic state leader when he ordered
American troops withdraw from northern
Syria earlier this month for months
intelligence officials had kept Trump
apprised of what he had set as a top
priority the hunt for mr. al-baghdadi
the world's most wanted terrorists
apparently Pentagon officials had to
speed up their plan for the risky night
raid before their ability to control
troops spies and reconnaissance aircraft
disappeared with the pullout so the
Syrian pullout meant that we had to
speed up the timetable which means again
the American military are unbelievable
at what they do I mean just the greatest
in world history and what they do more
than a half dozen Pentagon military
intelligence and counterterrorism
officials provided a chronology of the
raid the planning for the raid began
this past summer when the CIA first got
surprising information about all
Baghdadi's general location in a village
deep inside a part of northwestern Syria
controlled by rival al Qaeda groups the
information came after the arrest and
interrogation of one of mr. al
Baghdadi's wives in the courier to
American officials said armed with that
initial tip the CIA worked closely with
Iraqi and Kurdish intelligence officials
in Iraq and Syria to identify more
precisely all Baghdadi's whereabouts and
to put spies in place to monitor his
periodic movements American officials
said the Kurds continued to provide
information to the CIA on all Baghdadi's
location even after Trump's decision to
withdraw American troops left the Syrian
Kurds to confront the Turkish offensive
alone the Syrian and Iraqi Kurds
according to one official provided more
intelligence for the raid than any other
single country according to Syrian
engineer who spoke with villagers living
near the raid site al Baghdadi had
sought shelter in the home of abu
mohammed salameh
a commander of another extremist group
who razo al deen the commander's fade in
that rate and the precise nature of his
relationship talk about Daddy are not
clear as the Army's elite Delta Force
commando unit began drawing up and
rehearsing and plans to conduct the
mission to kill or capture the ISIS
leader they knew they faced formidable
hurdles the location was deep inside
territory controlled by al Qaeda the
skies over that part of the country were
controlled by Syria and Russia the
military called off missions at least
twice at the last minute the final
planning for the raid came together over
two to three days last week a senior
administration official said all about
Daddy was about to move and military
officials sped up their timeline they
said if Baghdad he moved again it would
be harder to track
John with the American military pulling
out by Thursday and then Friday defense
secretary mark espera said on ABC's this
week that Trump quote gave us the green
light to proceed around midnight on
Sunday morning in the region 5 p.m.
Saturday in Washington eight American
helicopters primarily ch-47 Chinook took
off from the military base near Erbil in
Iraq flying low and fast to avoid
detection the helicopters quickly
crossed the Syrian border and then flew
all the way across Syria itself a
dangerous 70 minute flight in which the
helicopters took sporadic ground fire to
the Boresha area just north of in Lib
City in western Syria just before
landing the helicopters and other
warplanes began firing on a compound of
buildings providing cover for commandos
with the Delta Force and their military
dogs to descend into a landing zone
Trump said with helicopter gunships
firing from above the command was
bypassed the front door fearing a booby
trap before destroying one of the
compounds walls they then rushed through
and confronted a group of Isis fighters
apparently this is all being piped into
the White House Situation Room from
surveillance aircrafts orbiting over the
battlefield
Delta Force commandos under fire entered
the compound they shot and killed a
number of people as the Delta Force team
breached the wall with explosives an
Arabic linguist advised children and
other non-combatants to flee because
America is phenomenal a decision
commander is credited with saving 11 of
the children al-baghdadi had in his
compound I'll Baghdad even ran into an
underground tunnel with the American
commandos in pursuit Trump said that the
Isis leader took three children with him
presumably to use his human shield
because this is what terrorists do this
is why whenever you hear about the
United States negotiating with the
Taliban or Israel negotiating with
Hezbollah or Hamas or the Palestinian
Authority or Islamic Jihad just remember
that al Baghdadi is fairly typical of
terrorists a person who uses human
shields this way including a children
fearing that all - al Baghdadi was
wearing a suicide vest the command was
dispatched a military dog to subdue all
Baghdady and then he set off the
explosives did Baghdad he's setting and
killing the three children
espera said he's in a compound that's
right with a few other men and women
with him a large number of children our
special operators have tactics and
techniques and procedures that tried to
go through it and call them out at the
end of the day as the president said he
decided to kill himself and took some
small children with him I believe mr.
Esper did not say that the that didn't
repeat the whimpering and crying
assertion made by Trump he said the
president probably had the opportunity
to talk to the commanders
on the ground so you know we'll see if
that bears out or if that is from
getting poetic at 7:15 Washington time
on Saturday the special ops commander on
the ground reported all Baghdad he had
been killed five other enemy combatants
were killed in the compound and
additional enemies were killed in the
vicinity the American military is always
wounded in all Baghdad a suicide vest
explosion and was taken away by the way
I'm not a dog fan I will adopt that dog
in one heartbeat I mean come on that is
an amazing dog right there after the
raid the commandos removed the 11
children from the site and handed them
over to a woman in the area the military
then ordered the destruction of the site
to ensure it would not in the future
become a shrine to Isis all too
altogether American troops were on the
ground in the compound for about two
hours
also we scooped up DNA from the Isis
leader and they made a quick assessment
that they had the right man
and then after Americans pile back into
the helicopters and started returning to
Iraq American warplanes bombed the
compound to ensure that it was
physically destroyed which it the utter
badassery of the American military is
just spectacular it is just absolutely
incredible and spectacular and freedom
has no better friend and and journey no
worse enemy than the American military I
mean do not f what the American is the
end of that particular story Wow Wow Wow
okay meanwhile over the weekend there's
some talk about impeachment good 20:19
but a lot of the talk actually was about
this other investigation that is going
on late in the week it broke that the
Trump DOJ was opening a criminal
investigation apparently into Trump
Russia investigation itself into the
origins of the Trump Russia
investigation trying to figure out how
it was that all of this bad information
profused the American intelligence
services how the American intelligence
services use that information did they
violate the law in the use of that
information to go after members of the
Trump campaign and you can see Democrats
are pretty nervous about all of this
stuff Democrats are immediately trying
to do legitimize the investigation now
it's again it's funny the media and
Democrats will get very angry when Trump
D legitimizes the impeachment inquiry or
D legitimizes the Muller report but when
it comes to John ziram who is the lawyer
who's in charge of this particular
investigation and has a very very
serious reputation when it comes to John
ziram leading this investigation then
they have no problem downplaying the
veracity of the
vestigation Adam Schiff who wants to
investigate the president up to and
including his colonic movements Adam
Schiff suddenly has a real problem when
it comes to this investigation he says
you can assign good people and it's
still in an illegitimate investigation
look you can assign would you accept the
results of such an investigation it
wasn't say you can assign good people to
do an illegitimate investigation you can
assign good people to investigate the
president's political rivals it doesn't
mean that the investigation is any less
tainted this is tainted because of the
motivation which is a political one to
serve the president's political interest
oh you see it's a political
investigation when it's John Durham who
is not really a political figure
carrying it out because Adam Schiff
doesn't like any of this right and James
Comey is doing the same thing right
James Comey who presumably will come up
in this investigation he was fired at
the behest of President Trump because he
refused to say publicly that Trump was
not under investigation by the
intelligence services James Comey over
the weekend he said you know I think
this is John's room guy he might be
damaged I'm just concerned for John
Durham's reputation you know it's not
that I have any personal stake in this
I'm not worried about the investigation
at all but I think Durham might be
damaged I'm worried about his rap guys
that's really the issue here John Durham
is someone who has a strong professional
reputation someone I've for years
thought was an excellent prosecutor I
can't tell what's going on with the
Attorney General I would hope that mr.
Durham will do everything possible to
protect his reputation from being
damaged by those in leadership that was
Comey at political shift by the way came
out and ripped bill bar from weaponizing
the Justice Department here's what that
sounded like
bill bars Justice Department is doing a
criminal investigation of people who
properly looked into Russian
interference in our election in the FBI
or in the intelligence agencies it means
that bill bar on the president's behalf
is weaponizing the Justice Department to
go after the president's enemies I serve
for years I don't anymore on a
commission that would help emerging
democracies and we would always inform
the Parliament terms of these
democracies when you win an election you
don't seek to just prosecute the losing
side but this is what Bill Barr is
seeking to do he is demonstrating once
again that he is merely a tool of the
President
the president's hand okay so you can
tell that shift Comey people are a
little nervous I'm left side of the a
list what exactly this investigation is
going to come up with what exactly are
we gonna find at the root of the Trump
Russia investigation who was
coordinating with whom and was this
thing conducted in both good faith and
without violation of law Jonathan Swan
reporter from Axios very good reporter
he pointed out John's room has a very
serious reputation hey this is not a guy
who's gonna put his career on the line
for what he feels to be a bad
investigation from the very beginning a
politically motivated investigation here
Swan reporting John Durham has a very
serious reputation and I don't think
that at this point that decision he
thinks that we've reached a threshold
that we can open a criminal
investigation my guess based on his
reputation is that was based on facts we
don't know what that criminal aspect is
it could be a leak investigation it
could be something to do with classified
information we saw a lot okay so this so
again Swan is correct this is a serious
investigation I think Democrats are a
little bit worried about it meanwhile
the media continue to run with
impeachment code 419 the latest breaking
news in that story is that apparently
apparently someone the the Gordon
summoned the US ambassador to the EU
apparently told House committees that he
believed that Ukraine agreed to open
investigation into bereavement group and
into alleged a 2016 election
interference was a condition for a White
House meeting between Trump and
Ukrainian President Vladimir Solinsky
according to someone's lawyer now that
is different from what someone had said
in his text messages with Bill Taylor
who was the highest ranking American
official in Ukraine in those text
messages Taylor had said this feels like
a quid pro quo and someone said no no
this is no quid pro quo but the question
is not really whether it's a quid pro
quo the question is whether it is an
illicit quid pro quo and I laid out that
entire theory of the case whether the
quid pro quo itself was illicit what
exactly was Trump requesting was he
trying to investigate the miasma
Ukrainian corruption that he was very
upset about because of 2016 or was it
more about getting Joe Biden and trying
to push the Ukrainian government into
investigating an American citizen is
that really what was it the crux of all
of this I tend to believe not I tend to
believe the first story but the media
are jumping all over this the White
House has taken the bizarre line that
there was no quid pro quo at all which
is a line I don't think is is really
effective at this point very early on in
this investigation I said it's not clear
there was
quid pro quo specifically because there
were multiple reports that Ukraine's
didn't even know it had been deprived of
military aid then as time went on it
became clearer that Ukraine knew that it
had been deprived of military aid and
also it became clear that they wanted a
meeting with President Trump that they
weren't getting yes there was a quid pro
quo the question is again whether it was
an illicit quid pro quo I'm John Kelly
who's the former White House chief of
staff he did an interview at the Sea
Island summit political conference
hosted by the Washington Examiner over
the weekend and he said listen I warned
Trump that he might be impeached if
there weren't advisers there to stop him
from making mistakes like this whatever
you do don't don't hire a yes-man
someone that's going to tell you or it
won't tell you the truth don't do that
because if you do I believe you'll be
impeached okay and the thing that the
Kelley is saying there is not that he
believes that President Trump is
constantly violating the law he believes
that he needs people around him to
inform him where the legal limits are
when something is a good idea when
something is a bad idea and frankly I
think that Kelley is not wrong here I
mean the fact is that if there have been
someone around from saying no you're not
allowed to outsource your Ukrainian
foreign policy to Rudy Giuliani stop
this nonsense if there had been someone
around from saying you know you really
shouldn't try to investigate what's
going on in Ukraine via wild rumors
being fed to you by your personal lawyer
right maybe Trump wouldn't listen but it
would be good to have somebody and Kelly
said I regret resigning because of all
of that he said that he wishes that
there had been somebody who was there
telling Trump no and then Trump
immediately fired back he gave a
statement to CNN he said John Kelly
never said that he never said anything
like that because Kelly said that he
told Trump not to hire a yes-man
Trump said John Kelly never said that he
never said anything like that if he
would have said that I would have thrown
him out of the office he just wants to
come back into the action like everybody
else does which is a very weird like he
doesn't want back into the White House
and then the White House press secretary
Stephanie Grisham she said I worked with
John Kelly and he was totally unequipped
to handle the genius of our great
president that is not a good way to
rebut charges that you have surrounded
yourself with yes people by the way if
somebody says you surround yourself with
u.s. people and you're like here is my
spokesperson who will say that you are
totally unequipped to handle my great
genius not the world's best rebuttal
there from president from
does this mean that Trump is guilty of
impeachable offenses no it doesn't it
means that Trump is more likely to run
directly into sinkholes political
sinkholes when there is no one there to
hold him back does that mean that he
purposefully ran into the sinkhole does
it mean that he should me no it just
means it would have been good to have
somebody saying to him no all right that
would have been a useful useful thing
okay time for a quick thing I like and
then a quick thing that I hate so quick
thing that I like today so there's a lot
of long rise we're here in Israel still
it's been a fantastic phenomenal trip
gotten a lot of opportunities to go to
some really cool places yesterday went
to Masada with the kids well that means
that we do have a driver over here for
security reasons and my not because it's
an insecure country just because I hate
him public figure in all this well in
any case I sit in the back of the car
and I've got kids on one's a kitten one
side and kid on the other and these are
long rides that means it's time to watch
some movies and the movies that they
want to watch always and forever are
Pixar movies they love the Pixar films
and honestly as an adult you don't end
up like when you're going out to a movie
with your wife you don't end up going
out to see Pixar films just as a general
rule but they're really great I mean
they're better than most of the movies
that are out there I hadn't seen
Incredibles - it's really good and
really funny so if you're looking for a
great movie to watch with their kids
tonight Incredibles 2 would be the movie
it really is like I left Harvard
incredible student I've laughed at any
comedy that I've seen in the last 5
years because it really is except for
maybe that that's the death of Stalin
it's really it's really good here's a
little bit the trailer for Incredibles -
did you wash your hands with soap did
you dry them I did so are we going to
talk about it what the elephant in the
room what elephant
mom's new job okay so it's a little bit
it's a little bit scary for for little
kids like my three-year-olds a little
bit scared by it not too much because
the the villain in it has kind of a
scary voice and a scary look but the all
the stuff with the little baby with it
with superpowers is pretty phenomenal
and it also has like half the cast of
Breaking Bad which is kind of hilarious
well yeah it's it's got the guy who
plays Saul
like better call Saul it's got Mike
Ehrmantraut so it's it's got this weird
crossover it's a lot of fun go check it
out totally worth the watch Incredibles
- okay time for a quick thing that I
hate so president Trump visited the
Nationals game last night and at this
Nationals game he was roundly booed
which is not a shock at all I mean he's
in Washington DC the crowd at the
Washington Nationals game is going to be
profoundly anti-trump they're cheering
the American troops they were booing
President Trump in this of course became
a national news story oh they booed the
President of the United States and yeah
yeah you know what if Barack Obama had
gone to a Houston Astros game in the
middle of the of his presidency
presumably he would have been booed as
well it's not really it's not really a
national news story but it is a story
because obviously whenever the president
is moved like that it's not a good look
I will say that the day that you kill
one of the world's leading terrorists
get booed in a ballpark is that's a
weird it's a weird thing from fans -
very weird thing from fans but you know
politics is politics I sort of got it
what is ridiculous what is purely
ridiculous is the is Saturday Night Live
so Saturday Night Live literally did a
skit on Saturday night I mean you're
talking about bad timing
Satur Night Live did a skit on Saturday
night in which they thanked Trump he had
it's had a terrorist some playing
terrorists thanking Trump for bringing
jobs back to Isis the day before the
morning before Trump announced the
killing of al Baghdadi's so here is this
SNL skit who's next you sir please
and where are you from son New Mexico
Isis yeah I was a prisoner in Syria
until last week when you freed me so I
just wanted to say thank you for
bringing jobs back to Isis and I promise
that I will make Isis great again yeah
and then we killed that by the way we
didn't just kill back daddy over the
weekend we also killed his right-hand
man we had a there's a I think we him
with a Hellfire missile which is a hell
of a way to go so bringing jobs back to
some bad timing there from Saturday
Night Live okay we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of celebrity content
because I mean hey it's a great day in
America and the less when you kill the
world's leading terrorists that's a
pretty good thing we'll be back here
later to talk about it I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua Olvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew clave and host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me
Andrew clip
[Music]